We have travelled quite a bit
in our QMV diagrams here.
We started by asking questions as to how
one should detect anomalies in data.
We thought we could detect
outliers in distributions.
We inspected distributions and
looked at correlations between them.
We derived certain variables.
We used two variables
to form some model.
The models we looked at could have
been parametric, non-parametric, or
mathematical.
We concentrated on
the non-parametric models and
derive some single variable
kernel density estimates.
>From the single variate kernel density
estimate, we look for optimal models.
We used mean integrated square error
to look for optimal bandwidths.
We introduced the KL divergence.
We also found some multivariate
kernel density estimators and
looked at joint probability
distribution functions.
For the multivariate methods,
we looked at outliers in the models.
We used Mahalanobis distance
to find the outliers and
we left it up to you to find out what
these outliers may mean in our data.
This completes this part of our lesson.
At this point,
we will leave behind this diagram.
However, you can see there
are many points we could have
further enhanced this diagram.
In fact,
this is always the case with our Q and
V diagrams to find the flow of
logic in model building process.